hi there today we're going to take a
look at the open AI microscope and this
article on the still called feature
visualization so the feature of
visualization article is by Chris Ola
Alexander morte Vint Cerf and Ludwig
Schubert of the Google brain team while
the opening I microscope is by open AI
so keep that in mind these tools are
tools for visualizing what neural
networks learn and specifically here
we're dealing with image classifiers and
even more specifically image net
classifiers so you know image net is
this big data set with a thousand
classes of images and the images are
somewhat like 200 by 200 pixels and
you're just supposed to put them into
one of these 1000 classes and networks
have become really good at these kinds
of things so our question is what do
these networks learn and there are a
number of very cool works that have
started to investigate what these
networks learn so this started with work
like deep dream or even before that but
this is a very good summary and also and
also overview of this so in this article
they first showcase these patterns here
where you can see that as you go through
the network in the layer this is layer
come to d0 which is a very low layer in
the network you have things what looks
like pattern just pattern detectors so
these are the things that the network is
excited and will just get or get in a
second at how you create these things
just be sure these are the things that
the these particular layers in the
networks are most excited by so this
that this layer is super excited by
these textures right then but as you go
higher the network gets excited by these
kind of textures then it gets excited by
more calm
things right so the pattern is the
higher you go in the layers and this
people have been seeing and claiming
this and measuring this since RBF
networks and whatnot that that the
higher you go in these networks the more
complex features that they build so they
always build hypotheses they build very
complex features from the lower layers
and the lower layers they have less less
complex features and until you're the
very bottom layer they simply extract
edges and and patterns of texture like
this whereas in the top layers all of
these are hierarchically assembled to
give you very very intricate features so
these usually look pretty funky that's
why I like to investigate
so these article focuses on how is this
done and the answer is by optimization
now what do we mean I actually have the
article here somewhat printed out but
the graphics they don't really print
very well to to to the notebook here so
imagine this here so what you want to do
is you want to see how act how much
activation is in the network for a
particular input and you can do this in
many many different ways the easiest
form let's actually start over here if
you have a neural network here and this
is the softmax cluster and these are the
classes in this case let's say this is
dog this is cat and this is car house
let's go with house you can you can
think of okay I want to I want to know
when the network sees a cat what does
the network think of cats so what I
would do is I would take an image that
is just noise right just random noise
like
this one on the left here and I would
start to optimize using back propagation
I would start to optimize this image now
you usually know back propagation as the
thing that will optimize these weights
if we have given an image and the label
right but right now you have to so and
we optimize the the weights here sorry I
should say Doe right but right now you
have to rethink what we have given is
the label and the weights we keep them
constant but we optimize the input image
to maximize this label as much as
possible so we ask of X X please please
update yourself such that the output is
as much cat as possible right and then
we we just optimize for that and so we
hope that this picture would turn out to
be as much cat as we like right and
usually here I don't know exactly which
class they have here but you won't get a
cat sorry over here you won't get a cat
or here if you optimize the log it's
it's the same just you do the same thing
before the softmax what you will get is
some real trippy thing
so in our classifier you might get
something like so there's a cat here but
there's also one here right because two
cats are more cat than one cat and there
is like a giant cat head here and inside
the cat head there is another cat head
and there is like a cat tail somewhere
here and again this there's a cat eye
right here so you get like something
something super trippy that is as much
capped as possible all right now so the
this is somewhat somewhat interesting
because you can find out what
what does network think is the most
cat-like thing there is and the most
doglike thing there is but what you can
also do is you can see what's do the
intermediate layers of the networks what
do they get excited by
so what you can do is for example you
can take an individual neuron in one of
the layers right so this here might be a
convolutional layer with its
convolutional filters right and these
are the different channels of the
convolutional layer and then this thing
here is just a single neuron there and
what you can do is you can you can you
can say okay X we have now again we
input the image X and we optimize the
image X search that with the given
weights this particular neuron let's
call it n and n is and it's maybe this
neuron right here right
this particular nirn is as much
activated as possible right so we no
longer optimize for a label but we
optimize for a particular neuron to be
activated as much as possible and then
we can sort of see what is an image that
activates this neuron as much as
possible in this case that thing you can
actually do the same thing with an
entire channel if you simply say when is
the channel as a whole activated as much
as possible and something like deep
dream did the same thing but with an
entire layer in the neural network like
what is this layer activated by they can
imagine there's not only one image that
activates it the most but probably
depending on your start here it's it's
it's a you'll get different different
results for depending on where you start
and we'll go into that later as well so
these are the kinds of things you can do
to investigate these neural networks and
see what they what they pay attention to
in each of the layers right so let's go
on here and so they say they say okay if
we optimized by optimization you get
something like this here
on the bottom row looks pretty funky
right but what you could also do is you
can visualize by what is called dataset
examples and date with data set examples
you don't do this thing you don't do the
optimization procedure but you go into
your into your database into your data
set and you find the images that
activate so the X I from your data set
that activate a particular neuron the
most so you simply sort all the images
in your database and you just pick the
ten or so that activate that particular
neuron the most and that would also give
you an understanding it's actually valid
thing and the AI microscope combines
both of them so on the bottom you see
what particular neurons are most excited
by and at the top you see that that the
the data set examples they're most
excited by so you can see that there is
a there is a healthy diversity in the
data set examples but they also all
kinda map to the to the what it's most
excited by it's pretty cool
the last point they make in this article
is that of diversity with the data set
examples you do get naturally sort of a
diverse set of images of course where
you can guess you can also say okay what
are the maximum activations and only
slightly positive you can even give
negative examples but with the positive
you can only either maximize fully or
you can you know take the negative and
you can say okay what is listener on not
excited by at all but you you won't get
kind of a spectrum of what the Newton
the neuron is excited by or the unit or
the layer and what they're doing is
simply they add a diversity term they
say that works best so what does that
mean it means that here if we optimize x
and y right let's go up here if we
optimize X in that right and
try to maximize the activation of n we
don't want to do X by itself but we want
to do is we want to do an entire set of
X I right so we feed an entire mini
batch in there and we want to maximize n
but also maximize a diversity term let's
call that D between the X 1 to X B right
so you want to maximize the activation
of the neuron but at the same time in
your a loss function that you optimize
you also have this diversity term where
you say the images that you produce
should be far apart from each other or
kind of apart from each other and thus
you do get diverse samples ok the
printing again doesn't work so here you
see that if you just simply optimize you
get the thing on the left but if you
have a batch of things and you optimize
them to be diverse from each other but
also activate the layer or the unit you
get a variety of high activations and
you can see here that this is some sort
of curve this could be a beak of a bird
but on the right here this could also be
kind of a snout of a monkey or something
okay so it's just curvy curvy things
that is activated by here they give
another example you can clearly see that
there is like some sort of eye in the
picture but then if you optimize with
diversity you can see that some of them
do not have this eye thing and in fact
also some of the data set examples do
not have this eye thing so it might be
interesting to to to optimize here with
diversity and even in they say in higher
layers it gets even more more diverse
with what you achieve with this ball
detector they also say they research
inter
actions between neurons where they can
interpolate between them right so you
can here have two different new units
let's say this top left one here is the
thing that we've just seen with the
curvature activator and then on the
right we can select this thing here that
is appears to be activated by these
bird-like bird-like things and if you
optimize an image that activates both of
them you get the thing on the bottom
left and this is very good for
understanding how neural networks work
because what a neural network will do is
exactly it will take the thing on the
top left and the top right from lower
layers and it will combine them to form
features of higher layers so while the
top right thing looks like Generic Birds
the bottom-left thing looks much more
like birds with let's say long necks and
then kind of curve next so more stork
ish birds right because we've added in
this curvature thing so this is very
very cool to play around you can also
here interpolate between mintu neurons
like you would interpolate in a in again
right and yeah so they do make a point
of regularization I don't want to go
into that particularly but you have to
be careful you can't just apply the
optimization procedure as I said right
now you have to actually have to do some
regularization and to get to get rid of
what are essentially adversarial
examples in this process because if you
just straight-up optimize you will get
pretty high frequency crappy results I
actually want to jump over now to this
opening a microscope so this is a tool
that lets you explore these
visualizations so at the beginning you
can pick one of these models and I'll
pick inception v1 just because some of
the other ones they don't have
everything done quite yet the all the
all the all the visualizations so on the
right here you can actually see the
architecture of the network
you know what an inception network is
this looks like and you would be able
from here to select one of these units
straight away but I'm gonna sorry we're
gonna go to the left here so you have
deep dream activated which means the
entire layer is optimized for so per
layer on the right side you have an
image here and you can already see that
if we go from the bottom what we saw
before we get patterns that become more
and more complex as you go up the layers
and then more and more until you finally
have what the network appears to be most
activated by is mostly dogs which is
okay because imagenet is dominated by
dogs so you can click on any of these
right here like this one and now you'll
be able to to inspect the individual
nodes in this layer so before we had the
whole layer right the whole layer was
activated by something but these layers
they have different channels and also
different neurons within the channel so
you can select this here you can go
neuron activation or channel activation
and these are the images that these
channels are excited by the most you see
you get pretty funky pattern if we
select one interesting one maybe this
this one right here you can see on the
left this is the channel optimizing
optimization on the right this is the
neuron optimization and here you get the
data set examples that are most
activated that mostly activate this
particular channel or neuron so sorry
this particular yeah channel so you can
see this is pretty similar to the thing
I drew where except for it being a cat
it's some sort of a Fox dog thing
right and and you can explore the neural
network in this fashion so you can go
through the layer here and look at look
at units this seems to be whiskers a
classifier and lo and behold things with
whiskers will activate the the neuron
and as you go up the layer and this is
the the cool thing right so we right now
we're here in this layer for as you go
up you will see more and more intricate
patterns of activations i I could I have
this for very very long time but I won't
I won't waste your time too much they
there is this sorry there is a a slack
workspace where people discuss
interesting patterns what is this
okay yes this is a some sort of temple
temple constructor very cool
there is a slack workspace where people
discuss interesting things for example
they discuss how the car detector that
you see right here is one of the units
there is literally endless units to look
at that detects cars can be clearly seen
to be built from lower level features
such as this wheel detector you see this
wheel detector here is the unit 3 3 7 in
the mixed 4 layer and this car hood
detector right here is unit 2 3 7 also
in the in one of the layer force right
so these are both from layer 4 and then
the core detector as you look this up ah
isn't layer 4 as well but it let's check
it out
this isn't layer 4 B this isn't layer 4
B and this isn't layer Force
ah so you see I this was a risk the car
detector is built from lower level
features of car hood and car wheel right
the car wheel right here detects wheels
and the car hood detector detect hoods
and then the car detector detects cars
so there are very like I really invite
you to go look at it check out what
people find and explore these models all
of this is based on this lucid library
right here also invite you to check that
out where you can perform such
optimizations yourself link to that and
with that bye bye